you said something really interesting
and that was shooting two people talking
is one thing but in terms of you may not
really grow from that what do you think
is tougher adding more actors to the
production or sort of a location that's
out in the public arena and there's no
telling what could happen sometimes more
people make things much more complicated
oh yeah yes it does very much
I mean then getting all that coverage
and all those personalities and also
serve and making sure that you're
getting enough coverage to tell the
story with all those people moving
around I mean like Jeff Darren's last
this recent feature like they were both
ensemble casts and this recent one much
more so and like that that was like you
know that I mean like it's you know it's
it's it's it's you know it's it's it's
you know it's it's tough you know it's
tough trig again all that coverage like
you know II you just gotta like I mean
you just got a cast well and you just
gotta like almost so I just put a member
like John Carpenter said something when
he was like shooting the thing because I
had such an ensemble cast and a lot of
people on screen at one series like just
put the camera on the middle and just
kind of like go clock like clockwork you
know and then just get that person get
that person you know like and but if
you're like outside the circle you're
like completely screwed so that's like I
was like a nice thing but yeah but I
think shooting in a public place I think
yeah I mean like that it's the worst
when you don't have like permits or
something or like blocking off streets
or doing you're not allowed to do lockup
so people I mean like I mean I make it
make it a movies like and it's a
nightmare I mean it's like it's just I
mean there's so many now it's like
there's so many and there's there's so
many
I'm eeeeenh and whenever a movie gets
made and it's actually good like it's
like it's it's a miracle honestly
because like there's so because people
watch like the most simplistic thing
about a movie they just see the finished
product but it's like you said I I you
know I try to watch as many
documentaries about the making of movies
like I just go through like there's many
making of featurettes as I can just like
see what these guys are going through or
there was when they were going through
making these movies and and like just
you know it's any it's like this you
know it's like everything everything
goes wrong like all the time and like
that but that's like that's the job
like you know that's um it's designed to
be very very difficult and but but at
the end of day it's like you're making a
move in it's like the coolest thing in
the world you're creating a world you
know it's like you're creating an
artificial universe and so I think like
but that's the but in order to design
make-believe it's like you know they're
you know you gotta eat you know I eat
some pizza you know concrete a little
bit you know and like that but that's
that's that's all part of it I mean
making movies like from pre-production
to filming at post-production you know
it's like I mean I'm just like I go
through like extreme depression
throughout eat all segments because let
you just care about it more than
anything in the world and you just want
it to be the greatest thing in the world
or the best movie you know how to make
at that time and it just means
everything to you so it's like
throughout production filming and most
production you know at least from my
personally like very depressed to myself
because I'm just trying to UM just just
trying my hardest to get what's inside
my head on screen and and you're just
battling so so many so many things just
fighting against you but it's like but
at the end of day is just like the only
thing that truly matters it's like
what's inside the frame you know it's
like everything around the frame no one
gives no one cares about at all when
they watch the movie so it's like I
think that should always be in the back
of your head because I think so many
people
I feel like focus more on what's going
on around the frame they like the
presentation of being a director that
they forget what they're actually
photographing and and a yeah I think
it's always about like what's inside the
frame and nothing else matters and and
so it's like that just like extreme
focus you know on that director's
monitor and around the scene and you
know I mean like I think like like
Stanley Kubrick said described
filmmaking which i think is so on the
money like you described filmmaking
saying like it's like reading war and
peace while in bumper cars or whatever I
was like that's that's yeah I mean
that's pretty much what it is
it's like trying to be so focused with
like all these explosions going on
around you and but but that's like you
know that but filming is my favorite
part if anything I mean a lot of people
find editing their favorite part
filming's my favorite part because I I
think my
energy translates more to filming
because like editing you're like sitting
down it's like a lot of sitting you know
you're sort of like just you know the
last chance to save the movie and you're
so you know it's just you and the editor
and and then you and the composer and
all that but both filming it's like I
love multitasking I love like I love
communicating to multiple people at once
and I because I just I'm such an anxious
and patient person that I just love to
like just constantly moving moving
moving you know like I'm moving forward
all the time and and that's why I you
know that's you know that's you know
that some you know sometimes I having a
truncate it's or a very tight schedule I
think lends itself well to you because
you know I think perhaps maybe if you
have a really long schedule you might
people might get lazy or something
because they think oh just shoot it
tomorrow
you know say it because I think it's
very sometimes very good so I mean you
don't want a super short schedule but
like but like I think like the the right
balance of time where it's like tight
but it's not super tight where it's like
you know I think like you know like 25
days or something that's like I think
that's like the ideal or like 30 days or
something like that's like an ideal
schedule for movies but I think or maybe
even 40 I don't know but but yeah
you